if you are flying today Sherry it's
looking like it's going to be a pretty
easy like getting out at least well and
flying into Las Vegas not bad it depends
on what's going on on the other end so
we've got some high clouds in fact
they're just kind of fanned out across
our skies this morning they're all
coming in from the North Sun on its way
up trying to work against those clouds
this morning they'll be heavier this
morning and we'll have more good
Sunshine through the afternoon we've got
some chilly 30s out on the east side
otherwise lots of 40s around the valley
a little breeze in the mountains and
then we're going to get more wind along
the Colorado River Valley from Lake Mead
to Boulder City down to Laughlin by
tonight 30's in Mesquite 40's in
Laughlin near freezing in Pahrump 28 up
in Indian Springs right now it's a cold
front that's moving through the state
and behind it by tonight will be those
Northerly winds so wind advisories
issued for the Colorado River Valley
Southern Clark County into Southeast
California along I-15 those start at 8
o'clock tonight and go until 6 p.m on
Thursday Thanksgiving fire weather
watches Santa Ana winds with wind
advisories all through Southern
California there along the coast if you
happen to be traveling it will be quite
windy today and tomorrow snow in the
northern Rockies will stay dry in most
of the West cold across the Upper
Midwest and showers and thunderstorms
from Texas to Florida could present some
travel snarls at the airport 67 degrees
for us today will be the warmest day of
the week with both Northerly winds
temperatures drop back to the low 60s by
Thanksgiving afternoon so you might want
to just keep the oven on and keep things
warm if you're going to be cooking
tomorrow after that Friday shopping
looks great with low 60s less wind and a
nice weekend before a chance of rain and
much cooler 50's early next week